Ciao ciao a tutti Intanto grazie mille
di essere arrivati così numerosi il Ted
per me è un appuntamento straordinario
già ne ho fatti cinque quindi interagire
con persone anche se purtroppo non vedo
tutti è veramente meraviglioso
l'argomento di oggi è fondamentale per
me per quelli che fa nel mio lavoro
anche per tante persone che fanno anche
altro però la passione è quella con cui
io credo che ci si nasce una frase che
praticamente Questa mattina ho scritto è
la passione crea delle emozioni e ti fa
ragionare e leggo la prima immagine per
quanto riguarda appunto la mia passione
a mia mamma che c'è ancora ringraziando
Dio Ho 63 anni ancora la curo come se
fosse una bambina
che non c'era una mattina a casa quando
io ero piccolo che mi Svegliarsi e non
sentivo il profumo delle mele e della
cannella perché lei tutte le mattine mi
faceva una torta e non è un dovere né
assolutamente una fonte di
nutrizione era solamente la passione
della Nutrizione perché tutti noi come
voi sapete ovviamente Siamo tutti figli
di donne quindi la donna è la prima
cuoca dell'umanità che con grande
passione ci ci gestisce all'interno del
suo corpo Praticamente ci fa nascere E
ci nutre e la nutrizione il rispetto Per
la nutrizione per la materia prima
è appunto la casa cioè Tutto nasce per
noi cuochi da un progetto di casa la
casa intesa come tavolo come riunione
come un momento di convivialità di
grande rispetto per quelli per i
contadini che hanno coltivato e raccolto
Praticamente i prodotti La grande
passione che oltre il vento la pioggia
le intemperie Praticamente ci permette
di fare qualcosa ogni giorno secondi
tipo industriale Con tutto che rispetto
parlando per le catene industriali Ma
per la mia cultura Io praticamente ma mi
riferisco a quelle persone che creano
qualcosa con le mani e con la mente la
passione è anche un progetto di famiglia
di figli Io per esempio in questi ultimi
anni ho cambiato tantissimo il mio che
concetto appunto di passione perché per
ora negli ultimi quattro anni dedico più
tempo possibile ai miei figli perché i
figli sono lo specchio della tua anima
che praticamente ti permettono di
guardarti e di correggerci
in corso d'opera I bambini sono
praticamente credo l'essenza più pura
della nostra umanità e per avere un
futuro migliore penso che praticamente
dobbiamo gestire ed educare benissimo i
figli alla passione più spontanea più
pura lasciarli praticamente
insegnargli e raccontargli qualcosa
e non obbligarli a fare qualcosa ed è un
pochettino che il mio lavoro che è
quello appunto di cuoco Io da quando ho
iniziato a fare questo lavoro da circa
28 anni e ho iniziato da autodidatta è
iniziato appunto per la passione che io
avevo dentro di me per la cucina che era
nata però da un dispiacere perché è la
passione è anche fonte di dispiacere Il
dispiacere era praticamente quello che
erroneamente nell'86 a 26 anni sono
andato in carcere un anno erroneamente
però la grande passione che avevo per me
stesso per la vita per per non buttarsi
giù perché ovviamente ero innocente
Altrimenti o non sarei qua praticamente
mi ha portato a riscoprire attraverso
una difficoltà una passione che io tempo
ogni giorno accanto che era quello
dell'ingrediente della materia prima
della trasformazione quindi il rito
della cucina Era attraverso gli
ingredienti che mia mamma ogni settimana
e mi portava appunto dentro il carcere
quindi io sentivo i profumi di casa del
bucato per la biancheria della frutta e
che verdura per gli ingredienti quindi
uscito da questa bruttissima esperienza
però con un bagaglio interno enorme
perché lì ovviamente il cervello inizia
a ragionare in un'altra maniera Quindi
tu sei chiuso in uno spazio piccolissimo
devi assolutamente convivere con persone
non è che puoi andartene praticamente
Quindi devi far uscire dentro di te
tutta quella forza d'animo che ti deve
sostenere per far sì che quando esci
metti a frutto la tua grande passione la
mia passione era diventata Appunto
quella di cucinare per altri quindi
decisi di trasferirmi a Roma perché
precedentemente facevo il fotoreporter
io per 12 anni ho fotografato tutta la
guerra di mafia giù a Palermo con
Letizia battaglia Quindi praticamente ho
conosciuto una città da tutte e le sue
sfaccettature però tutta questa cosa mi
ha portato Praticamente ad andarmene da
Palermo e quindi mi misi a cucinare per
gli altri a Roma e scoprì che quello che
per me era normale era un momento di
convivialità Praticamente per gli altri
era un autentico lusso il lusso delle
proprie tradizioni delle proprie
passioni e quindi decisi di diventare
cuoco
Ma il cuoco non è solamente quello che
cucina Io ho avuto sempre dei percorsi
un po' particolari perché il mio ruolo
probabilmente è la mia visione allargata
di tutto e mi ha portato sempre a
gestire delle grandissime cose quindi il
primo approccio praticamente che ebbi
con questo lavoro a Roma che per me era
sempre una passione non un lavoro come
oggi praticamente che mi portava a
raccontare agli altri la mia visione
diversa di questo lavoro quindi non
quello accademico tecnico che poi a
volte se tu sei un'accademico è un
tecnico non comunichi alla gente
praticamente
qualcosa di importante e di strutturato
al livello praticamente di sentimenti
perché il cuoco deve lavorare
assolutamente con una dose piattaforma
di sentimento e di altruismo non esiste
che un cliente va in un ristorante
chiede una cosa e il cuoco o il
cameriere per lui dice questa cosa non
si può fare cioè il cuoco è quello che
praticamente cucina per gli altri Se il
cliente non viene al ristorante
Praticamente il cuoco non lavora quindi
l'altruismo che ci deve essere intorno a
questo lavoro passione praticamente
divertimento anche deve essere enorme
dentro di me e dentro noi c'è
praticamente una parte di cantastorie il
cantastorie chi è È quello che racconta
qualcosa la gente ha bisogno di essere
di rilassarsi quell'ora in maniera
tranquilla ma di avere qualcuno sempre
attento alle loro esigenze Quindi quello
che noi dobbiamo trasmettere alle
persone e la passione la passione di un
lavoro che oggi
Permettetemi di dirlo
forza non c'è più non c'è più
praticamente perché è rimasta solamente
a pochi della mia generazione
e noi ci scontriamo oggi praticamente
mettiamo in discussione anni e anni di
duro lavoro di imporre che praticamente
alla nostra personalità di andare in
giro a parlare come oggi però poi
rientri a casa tua nel tuo ristorante e
non sai a chi trovi al lavoro perché
oggi purtroppo praticamente si parla
solamente
solamente di persone che vengono
sfruttate nel settore soprattutto della
ristorazione che non è affatto vero e se
lo dico in pubblico è così perché io per
esempio ma lo dico non per sponsorizzare
una razza che è quella del cuoco Oste No
È solamente una realtà Perché io mi
ricordo ho iniziato a fare questo lavoro
in tarda età è stato nelle cucine dei
luoghi dove mi pagavano per stare 8 ore
io ci stavo 22 ore ma ci stavo 22 ore
perché io volevo stare 22 ore perché
volevo assolutamente imparare qualcosa
dovevo respirare l'aria della passione
dovevo interagire con tutti i turni del
Lavoro dovevo capire Quello del lavaggio
Che cosa faceva con passione perché il
lavapiatti in Italia non c'è un
lavapiatti italiano è già Praticamente
questa cosa la dice lunghissima perché
siamo una popolazione di fighetti capito
proprio di fighetti perché non c'è un
ragazzo che va a fare il lavapiatti come
se fosse praticamente L'ultimo dei
Mestieri Cioè che il lavoro più
dignitoso di una cucina di un ristorante
perché la pulizia passa attraverso il
lavaggio questi piatti Difatti quando
voi sentite che un bicchiere sa di uovo
lo sa che c'è questa cosa che crea
questo Blend il lavapiatti non c'entra
nulla è il proprietario che ogni mese
deve cambiare un filtro che costa €320
quindi lì la passione è messa da parte
lì praticamente vince il menefreghismo
quindi quel ragazzo che sarà lavaggio
ovviamente non italiano capite è
colpevolizzato pure per non aver lavato
i bicchieri Bene detto questo quindi noi
ogni giorno Per esempio io al ristorante
ricevo Ringraziando a Dio dopo tanti
anni di lavoro tantissime prenotazioni
da un anno e mezzo a questa parte io e i
miei colleghi non sappiamo assolutamente
a chi troviamo al lavoro
il ragazzo da me che ha 22 anni ha una
busta paga di
1.780 euro netti al mese
netti Cioè non lordi Netti
il mio lo chef Praticamente il cuoco
primis ha una busta paga di 3.800 euro
al mese netti
ora un ristoratore che ha una grande
passione Perché ci sono due figure di
ristoratori il ristoratore imprenditore
è il ristoratore cuoco Ok diciamo che
dovrebbero essere due figure separate
uno fa i conti e l'altro fa l'artista
Però tante volte questa figura è unica e
allora che succede praticamente che io
che faccio il cuoco imprenditore sono
spinto dal sentimento perché
l'imprenditore è più freddo e cinico
quindi ha una passione relativa verso
quello che il lavoro finale che è quello
praticamente di consolidare un luogo E
renderlo fruibile al pubblico Quindi
quand'è che un ristorante lavora quando
la gente praticamente apprezza le
atmosfere i colori il servizio la
materia prima buona l'accoglienza la
musica e le posate pulite bene i
bicchieri senza macchie di calcare Se
c'è una tovaglia deve essere
chiacchierata con ferro da stiro se tu
oggi dice a un ragazzo praticamente
stirami la tovaglia non te lo fa anche
se un rito meraviglioso Difatti me lo
faccio io Capito quindi oggi la mia
generazione di passionari
sentimentali e pieni praticamente di
passione ci ritroviamo con le ali
tappate e in più veniamo definiti degli
sfruttatori perché vogliamo raccontare a
chi ci sta intorno a noi un lavoro che
era meraviglioso Perché il nostro lavoro
meraviglioso Perché dare del benessere
alla gente trasmettere una passione
renderla partecipe di un progetto onesto
e meraviglioso
e oggi Io non leggo più praticamente
negli occhi dei collaboratori
Praticamente questa grandissima voglia
di portare a termine un lavoro di questo
tipo
non la leggo più perché noi ogni giorno
incontriamo con grande dedizione
migliaia di persone li dobbiamo
convincere gli dobbiamo raccontare
qualcosa di bello gli dobbiamo creare un
piccolo sogno attraverso il cibo che è
l'unico mezzo di comunicazione sano vero
e onesto
quindi che è successo è successo
praticamente che io il 31 marzo ho
deciso di mettere la mia società e
liquidazione e ho chiuso il ristorante
perché voglio continuare a fare di me
Praticamente quello per cui sono nato
stare con la gente e farla stare bene e
io in quel momento in Quegli ultimi
periodi che tutto coincide con la AC
avanti covid dopo covid perché è ac/dc
tanto per ritornare al Rock di ringaccio
capito perché che succede che chi è
stato a casa chiuso ha detto ma io che
vita faccio a prescindere capito che
vita faccio lavoro sempre non mi piace
non è così Bisogna lavorare per creare
qualche cosa per creare praticamente dei
bei ricordi per creare grandi passioni
per creare praticamente spunti
importanti per le nuove generazioni
il lavoratore va rispettato questo è
sacro io fino al 2014 ero a busta paga
quindi so benissimo cos'è il mondo del
lavoro però tra praticamente credere di
fare qualcosa e non farlo praticamente
c'è di mezzo un universo Grazie
[Applauso]